you mentioned observing the uh the the
bucket uh I guess where in the basement
was that located
as you go down the stairs if you turn to
the immediate right it was at the bottom
of the stairs to the right
it was in pretty close proximity to the
stairs yes
um
after you made that observation what did
you do
uh after I pulled the towel off yes
um I had officer plancke come downstairs
and just verify we had in fact found a
human head in the bucket and then we
started to notify a supervisor and then
ask for additional units
on February 23rd 2022
did your department utilize body worn
cameras yes is that something that was
operating uh
on that day yes and did you have the
chance to review your body worn camera
prior to your testimony today yes I did
if you were able to observe that here in
court would you be able to to recognize
it yes you'll be able to okay
okay
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard
all right
come here
The Voice
this is
okay hold on
right
here
four at one
[Music]
I uh I know you're busy over there but
this is actually what it's going to be
it's not going to be a 961 thing around
96 thing so we're gonna do more unit
tape
that's
what
it's
that red one
uh no fur right now
if we can get more units here sooner
rather than later that'd be appreciated
um we've got
quite a bit of blood down here I want to
throw this rest of this house we've got
two people in the house for sure
foreign
[Music]
for the record the entirety of Exhibit 2
approximately 5 minutes 59 seconds was
played
officer having reviewed uh the exhibit
uh do you recognize the video that was
depicted yes I do does that appear to be
consistent with your body worm camera
footage that you observed yes it is and
does that appear to also be consistent
with your recollection of the scene on
Stony Brook Lane on February 23rd
correct I'd move exhibit two any
objection no objection the exhibit two
will be received
um so officer I want to ask a few
questions about that when you arrive
which door to the residence did you
enter through
I would have been the side door off the
driveway okay and was there a sort of a
storm door that was a part of that door
as well yes I believe so all right
um after you uh observe the the bucket
it appeared that you walked around the
basement area of the residence is that
right yes it did at that point did you
see any other parts of a human body
no other parts of the human body no did
you notice any areas of potential blood
yes and where was that uh beyond the
stack of mattresses there appear to be
Blood on the floor and then small chunks
of human flesh
there was a dried blood stain on the
mattresses and that was all that I
remember seeing
you and officer plonky was that the
officer who was also depicted in that
video yes it is did other officers
arrive on scene yes
and uh what did you and the other
officers do at that point
uh Sergeant brester was next to arrive
on scene uh kind of informed him of what
we had up to this point and then what we
needed to do next we have had two other
officers responding once we got all the
officers there that we needed we
conducted a protective sweep of the
residents just to make sure there is no
other people that we need to know about
just to make sure that there is no other
potential
threats
and uh you're the first officer to
testify so we'll I'll ask you this
because we've heard this term what is a
protective sweep
um it's it's not a search or anything
like that it's just a conducting a sweep
of the house just to make sure there's
no other people hiding or no other
threats
so essentially a search for people yeah
okay uh other than the towel that you
lifted off the bucket was any object
moved or rummaged through by officers
not the initial responding officers no
okay